I think one of the most famous,
one of the most dangerous in human
impulses is at,
is the idea that you can start from
scratch.
So this is,
this is an idea that has come up again
and again in history,
I almost called my book blank is
beautiful because it seemed to be this
recurring idea that was at the root of
this dream of transformation through
disaster transformation,
through shock,
through violence.
And I don't think by any means that the
right or the who are the market
fundamentalists have,
are the only ones who think this way.
I think it's the indicator species for a
dangerous ideology,
a,
it's the year zero mentality of a pol
pot or the desire for a blankness,
some cleaning,
the slate of Mal,
uh,
but you hear it from the Donald
Rumsfeld's and the Chinese as well.
This idea that you can create a country,
a model country in somebody else's land.
It's the same dream of,
of,
of total power,
total creation.
Um,
it's,
it's the colonial dream as well.
It's a and M.
I think we are in denial that this is a
deep part of our history here in North
America,
this dream of starting over,
of rebooting the world.
It's embedded in some of our most
powerful,
Judeo Christian biblical myths of the
great floods and great fires and just a
gang of us and our friends being saved
and getting to start over,
you know,
Noah's Ark and the rapture.
I mean,
we are,
we,
it's,
it's an amazingly seductive idea.
This idea that you can reboot the world,
start from zero.
Um,
it's an amazingly anti human idea and I
think we need to understand that because
it can be framed as a really idealistic
concept,
right?
We will,
we want utopia.
That sounds good.
Uh,
and we,
we know how to build it up.
But the problem with this dream is that
people get in the way,
right?
So then you have to clean the slate.
You have to wipe,
wipe the slate clean because there are
no empty lands.
And that was the violence of
colonialism.
I think it's been the most.
It is the most powerful,
most dangerous idea.
It crosses political lines.
It crosses religious lines,
uh,
and it,
it,
it is the ideology that has rationalized
the great cleansings,
the great genocides,
um,
and we need to identify it as a
dangerous ideology.
We need to understand it in our history
so that we don't repeat it.
Um,
and you know,
and we need to counter it with something
else.
And in terms of my philosophy,
I try try sort of developing a
philosophy is the opposite of starting
from scratch,
which is starting from scrap.
Um,
because I think this,
this idea that we see that there will be
some moment when we get to start from
scratch.
We need,
we need to,
to excise it.
Um,
there,
there are no empty lands,
there are no blank slates,
there are no clean sheet.
There's always gonna be people there who
disagree with you.
You're always going to have to start
from compromise.
Uh,
and um,
you know,
one time I interviewed William Gibson
who's a wonderful science fiction
writer,
or he doesn't only write science
fiction,
um,
but I was talking to them about science
fiction writing and he was,
he was saying that there's sort of two
different kinds of science fiction
writers,
the people who believe that the future
is shiny and the people who know that
the future is rusty,
right?
Um,
and,
and it's,
it's the shiny science fiction writers
that you have to worry about.
Um,
and,
uh,
you know,
I,
I think the future is going to be rusty.
I think it's going to be built by
whoever's around and whatever's left
behind and it'll be this sort of
patchwork and we just need to resign
ourselves to that,
that we,
you know,
we leave,
we leave big messes behind and um,
and we need to start from scrap and
stopped dreaming of starting from
scratch because it's,
it's a very violent idea and it sounds
wonderful.
But the flip side of it,
of that clean slate idea is the scorched
earth is,
is the scorched earth we're seeing in
Iraq right?